white women are killing yoga purely for
their quest for Perfection to a white
woman Perfection means a key to
happiness your key to
success and the key to your very
existence you have to have the perfect
hair the perfect clothes the perfect
grades the perfect nails and then you
bring this competition for Perfection
into the yoga room into your yoga
practice did you know that this quest
for Perfection is rooted in white
supremacy I thought that this was going
to be that she's going after the white
women for appropriating yoga I thought
that's where this is going to go but
instead her actual complaint I guess she
she's mad at white women who are
attractive and do yoga while being
attractive and it makes her jealous and
so that is actually her complaint she
didn't go the appropriation angle